what started off as a spin-off to the
Spyro the Dragon video game series has
birthed an entirely new way to play
games games which coexist in digital
lands and our real-world real-world toys
which can be transported into video
games and those Skylanders may have been
first market back in 2011 in 2015
there's no shortage of toys to life
experiences for you to choose from but
which one of these experiences is best
suited for you and your kid well a lot
of this depends on your pop culture
poison of choice Marvel or Mario Doctor
Who or Pikachu all of these and more are
contained in the four games we're going
to talk about in this video
Lego dimensions Disney infinity
Skylanders and Nintendo's amiibos and to
talk about them we rounded up four
experts from C Ned and gamespot.com some
of these folks are parents
all of them are grown-up kids and each
has a particular affinity for one of the
four games on offer so let's get into it
so Skylanders is the granddaddy of the
toys to life genre which is good news
because it's likely you already have
some Skylanders toys from previous games
and all of those will be compatible with
the new game this year which is
Skylanders supercharges they're adding
cards to the mix so there's three types
of vehicles that you can now have your
Skylanders ride there's land vehicles
there's air vehicles and they're sea
vehicles you know despite the fact that
you will need to buy all these different
vehicles to actually complete everything
in the game you can complete the main
storyline without actually having to buy
anything outside of the main pack so the
main pack this year as it always has
done powde comes with you know a
Skylander and it comes with one of the
land vehicles as well on a pure gameplay
level Skylanders has always been for me
like them the most fun game to play with
my son and scholar and supercharges is
just you know it is really just you know
another step in the great heritage that
you know Scotland this series has and if
you're actually on a Nintendo platform
there are some Nintendo specific
characters that you can use both as
amiibo and as Skylanders all you need to
do is click the base and it goes from
one
to the other my choice for toys slice
has to be Nintendo's amiibo so amiibo
can only be used on the Wii U or the new
Nintendo 3ds and only with specific
games that support amiibo that's not to
say they're not amazing so for example I
could take this Mario figure and import
him into Mario Party 10 Yoshi's wooly
world for a custom Yoshi figure or I
could even import him into Mario Kart
where I could have a custom Mario racing
suit for my meat on top of that some of
me Bo have read/write abilities meaning
you can take an amiibo load your
character data on it and take it to a
friend's house and then load up your
Smash Brothers character right there in
their house on their Wii U it's a pretty
cool thing Nintendo has a deep well of
beloved franchises to choose from when
making amiibo and it definitely shows in
the product line I mean it starts at
Super Mario Brothers and goes all the
way through The Legend of Zelda Megaman
even Sonic the Hedgehog and Nintendo's
newest franchise splatoon also have you
seen how adorable these little woolly
Yoshi's are they're so cute I want to be
a best friend my toys to life poison of
choice is Disney infinity 3.0 edition
which came out a couple of months ago
it's on Xbox 360 Xbox one PlayStation 3
PlayStation 4 Wii U and it's just come
in on PC as well when you buy it you
basically get the software for the game
you got a couple of figurines at - and a
starter pack you let's get one of these
do a play set and these playsets are
kind of like the crooks of what you see
when you look up traders for this game
they're like normal sort of linear
platforming style experiences that are
based around one particular property
starter facts going to set you back
around the cost of a regular video game
the rabbit-hole fall into though however
is picking up these little dudes but the
thing that I like about Disney infinity
is not so much the playsets themselves
but the sort of hub world that you have
visit with quite often which is called a
toy box this is basically a place where
there's a bunch of mini-games there's a
the ability to build your own house and
sort of them equip it and add rooms to
it and then there's also this whole toy
box experience where you're basically
able to get all of these properties and
sort of make your own missions and make
your own levels so it's kind of crazy
the Disney almost allowed all the
properties to co-exist it's the
memorable moment
that happen in this game because of that
because of the variety of different
properties all interacting with each
other it's something that really makes
Disney infinity 3.0 a really fun and
special game for me
so Lego dimensions knits the first Lego
toys to live game it's available on all
platforms all console platforms so you
solve puzzles you know it's normally
using different Lego characters
switching in and out in order to solve
environmental puzzles opening doors
opening hatches building things out of
broken LEGO pieces in order to reveal
more doorways that kind of thing the key
difference is obviously this time it's
using real LEGO pieces now the starter
set that you'll buy in which you get
this this little thing but also gandalf
batman and wild style who's the
character from the lego movie you can
play the entire game from start to
finish with those three characters and
and this is this is key to where the
game gives us two other logo games which
have been tied to a single franchise
logo dimensions is tied to multiple
franchises so it's a really broad range
of stuff so you can see some of the
stuff down here got gandalf from Lord of
the Rings our portal back to the future
scooby-doo there's Scooby and Shaggy
Ninjago and as you go through the game
the characters that you play are going
to go through these different worlds
Gandalf wild style and Batman start in
The Wizard of Oz they go to they go to
Springfield to the Simpsons land they go
to scooby-doo world they go to all of
these kind of places and in terms of the
amount of franchises in the mouth IP in
the game it's a huge huge amount what
the additional characters in playsets do
is two things they unlock little side
missions that are inspired so if you buy
the back of the future pack you're going
to unlock an extra world inspired by the
back of future movies but it's not a
huge separate game that the game the
main game is all in the starter set now
the star sets a bit more expensive than
some of the other toys to life packages
it's a hundred bucks you know this is
really for me the first toys to life set
which is all about playing with the toy
as much as it is about playing with
video game Lego will actually stop the
game and encourage you to go and build
something now at the start you might be
building something like this - this
Batmobile halfway through the game it's
going to encourage you to rebuild the
Batmobile into a different configuration
so that you can unlock a different area
this turns into like a Batmobile with
like a sonic radar thing on the front
you're not just going to be doing
anything different the same tag right I
mean it but I'm playing with my son that
thing where the game stops and tells you
to go build Lego my son loves building
Lego and building Lego with him was like
an incredibly fun part of the game bring
it back with a full tank so those are
our thoughts on amiibo's Skylanders Lego
dimensions and Disney infinity let us
know what you think in the comments
below and for further coverage of all
the toys to life games stay tuned at
Gamescom and see Netcom
you